trente mille véhicules par jour
empruntent cet axe de la route
départementale 30 à hauteur de plaisir
autant d'automobilistes qui devrait donc
être soulagés et passer moins de temps
dans les bouchons
après trois ans de travaux la deux fois
deux voies est ouverte le dossier a tout
de même été lancée voici vingt ans c'est
une des caractéristiques je crois
aujourd'hui de la france
la multiplication des recours la
multiplication des d enquête et d
différentes phases administratives qui
sont inimaginables sont que bien entendu
on a rallongé les délais de réalisation
il faudrait j'espère que ce message doit
être entendu
c'est qu'il y ait moins de recours quand
on fait des infrastructures ont fait pas
pour embêter les gens ont fait pour
améliorer la vie des gens
la patience aura payé le doublement de
la route sa compagne de murs acoustiques
sur plus de 2 km es22 souterrain c'est
la base même d'une femme qui est les
fondamentaux pour que notre ville puisse
avoir des aspirations encore
supplémentaires dans un développement à
la fois commercial économique et un
cadre de vie parce que ça apporte
effectivement un grand confort à notre
ville
on aura beau heures brouillage ailleurs
on en a déjà beaucoup mois 87 millions
d'euros ont été investis 54 par la
région 33 par le département et les
travaux se poursuivent avec notamment à
l'automne une passerelle pour que
cyclistes et piétons puissent franchir
la nationale 12